we now have a respectable understanding
of the periodic table itself and the
atoms in them and now we're ready to
deal with molecules themselves and to
deal with molecules we have to have some
way of representing them and you
represent them with formulas and there's
two major actually three major ways to
represent a molecule one is the
molecular formula molecular formula
formula and the other is the empirical
formula and I'll do it in a different
color to differentiate it empirical
empirical formula and the difference is
well let's just talk about what the word
empirical means I remember when I first
took chemistry the teacher kept using
the word empirical well you know what
does empirical really mean I clearly did
not have a very deep vocabulary I forgot
what what age it was but it means it
means achieved through observation or
experiment or based on experience so if
someone says that they empirically
figured out X Y or Z that means that
they figured it out through an
experiment or they observed it the
molecular formula is essentially the
actual number of atoms in that molecule
let me show you what I'm talking about
so the empirical formula tells you what
people have observed maybe before they
even knew that there was such a thing as
atoms they what they would have observed
is the ratio of the atoms to one another
in a molecule without knowing in the
exact molecule how many of that atom
there are let me show you what I'm
talking about
so if I were to give you I don't know a
benzene benzene benzene
the molecular formula of benzene you
have six carbon atoms and you have six
hydrogen atoms now if you were you know
some chemist in the 1800's and you
didn't know about the actual atoms but
if you had a big bag of benzene and you
were to measure the ratio of the carbon
to the hydrogen that you had in that bag
you would find out that for every one
carbon you have one hydrogen so your
empirical formula is the ratio of the
two you don't know that each atom
actually has six of these but you know
that for every carbon there's a hydrogen
for every hydrogen there's a carbon and
the way to go back you can go from the
molecular formula to the empirical
formula very easily you just find the
greatest common divisor of the number of
atoms in the molecule so the greatest
common divisor of six and six is
obviously six you divide both of these
by six and you get the empirical formula
it's not easy or you pretty much can't
go back from the empirical formula the
molecular formula you've lost
information I don't know whether this
was c6h6 was it C - H - you just don't
know and I mentioned reading the video
that there's a third way to represent to
represent molecules and that's the
structural structural formula and we'll
do that off and on and we've already
done it a little bit let me show you the
structural formula for benzene would
actually say how the molecular formula
atoms are configured so benzene in
particular it's a very interesting it
looks like this it's often drawn like
this and you'll see this a lot when you
take organic chemistry but it looks like
a little hexagon where the vertices of
the hexagon are carbon atoms so let me
draw the carbon atoms in yellow so this
is carbon carbon carbon carbon carbon
carbon they have double bonds every
other carbon double bonds and then they
have single bonds to hydrogen let me
just do the hydrogen in another color in
another color let me do it in magenta
hydrogen
hydrogen and obviously the structural
formula gives you the most information
right then you can start to think about
gee how will this interact with other
things while the molecular formula just
tells you what's in the molecule the
empirical formula really gives you the
least information it just tells you the
ratio of the different atoms in the in
the in the molecule structural formula
formula let's do a couple more okay what
if we're dealing with and enlisted
ladies let's say we're dealing with
water I think you know the molecular
formula for water h2o now what would be
the empirical formula for this well we
want to know the ratio so for every
oxygen there's two hydrogen or I guess
you could say for every hydrogen there's
a half of oxygen so you clearly can't
reduce this if I wrote this is h2o one
what's the greatest common divisor of
two and one well it's one so you just
have to divide it by one so in this case
the empirical and the molecular formula
are the exact same thing it's h2o what
about sulfur and sulfur is an
interesting an interesting molecule
because obviously it's just one atom
sulfur so I know I'm spelling it wrong I
want to it's not a pH it's F clearly I
should be making spelling videos so
sulfur sulfur so the molecular formula
s8 so it forms this neat kind of octagon
looking chain of sulfurs that's what
I've written in forward to draw that you
would see that and you could look it up
on Wikipedia if you like but it's
empirical formula if you had just a bag
of sulfur you don't know that each atom
has eight suffers you just have a big
bag of sulfur so the empirical formula
there's only one atom in this molecule
you divide by eight and you get s so you
just know that it all you've got there
is sulfur so let's just do one more
glucose
glucose pickle new color glucose the
molecular formula is C sorry edit undo
is c6h12o6 so for every carbon there are
how many for every six carbon there's 12
hydrogen and one oxygen so if you kind
of reduce this formula to its empirical
form what do you get let's see we can
divide all of these numbers by six so we
get one carbon two hydrogen's and one
oxygen so this just tells you the ratio
that they exist in a big bag of this
molecule this tells you the exact number
of atoms in that molecule fair enough so
now we know a little bit of the
difference between molecular formula
empirical formula and and and structural
formula now to see if we can use this
well we know about the formulas and the
periodic table to think a little bit
about the composition the mass
composition of some of these of some of
these molecules so the first thing to
even think about is how do you figure
out the molecular mass right let me I'm
a little periodic table down there so
molecular mass molecular mass or
molecular orful I don't want to say
let's say molecular mass so the first
question is how do you figure out how do
you feel I'm eeen the molecular mass is
going to be the sum of the all of the
atoms in that molecule right so if you
wanted to know the molecular mass of
let's say you want to know how much does
one molecule of benzene mass I don't
know you say it's a way because it
should be independent of what planet
you're on so how much how much what is
the mass of one molecule of benzene well
all you do is you add up the masses of
the different of the different
constituents so you have six carbons and
six hydrogen's so let's do benzene so
benzene benzene you have six carbons and
six hydrogen's so what's the mass of
each carbon so let's go back to the go
down to the periodic table just to give
proper credit I got this off of the Los
Alamos National
laboratories website so let's see the
atomic mass of carbon the reason why I
use this one instead of my previous one
is my previous periodic table that I got
off of Wikipedia only had atomic numbers
on them but now that we're actually
dealing with we're going to start
talking about the mass composition of
different atoms or different molecules
we're going to start looking at the
atomic mass right remember the atomic
mass when you think about an atomic mass
units it's just the number of protons
plus the number of neutrons so you have
six protons in carbon and roughly six
neutrons and why is this decimal because
we said before this is an average of all
of the the masses of the isotope so
you'll find in cuff of carbon so there's
a little bit of carbon-14 on the planet
very little but most of the carbon is
carbon-12
when you proportionately average them
you get twelve point oh one but let's
say we're dealing with you know
carbon-12 just going to some most common
element so carbon carbon carbon has an
atomic carbon is 12 atomic mass units
right and atomic mass used is a unit of
mass and we'll talk about how small it
is it's a very it's a very very very
very small fraction of a gram or
kilogram and we'll talk about that
probably in the next video so carbon is
12 atomic mass units what about hydrogen
let's see go to our periodic table
hydrogen's here in this dark blue and I
don't know if you can read it but the
atomic mass this is interesting the
atomic number of hydrogen is one the
atomic mass of hydrogen is 1.008
so that tells us that most of the
hydrogen on this planet has an atomic
mass of 1 which tells us that it
essentially has no neutrons that
hydrogen is a kind of a an interesting
nucleus there where there's really just
a proton just a proton sitting in that
nucleus and so if you were to if you
were to ionize hydrogen if you were to
turn into a cation and take one of its
electrons away what are you left with
you just have a proton a proton sitting
by itself just like a single proton
really is no different than a hydrogen
ion and that to me is kind of
interesting that hydrogen is that simple
it's really just a proton
so hydrogen has an atomic mass of 1
right if it had any hadn't need if it
hadn't any neutrons in it it would have
been it would have been you know at
least an atomic mass of 2 but hydrogen
is atomic mass of 1 one atomic mass unit
so how much does one molecule what is
the mass of one molecule of benzene
well it's 6 times the carbon mass so 6
times 12 plus 6 times the mass of
hydrogen time plus 6 times 1 so that is
6 times 12 is 72 plus 6 times 1 6 is
equal to 78
now what if someone said what percent of
benzene is carbon well then you say okay
well this is the piece that's carbon
right here the carbon piece of benzene
is 72 atomic mass units
right that's carbon so what percentage
of benzene is is carbon its well it's 72
over 78 the whole thing is 78 so it's 72
over 78 and what does that equal to me
let me get get a calculator going let me
get accessories I should have had my
calculator open ahead of time calculate
or there you go all right
so 72 divided by 78 72 divided by 70
eight is equal to 92 point three percent
so benzene is 92 point three percent
carbon by mass and of course the
remainder the seven point seven percent
is going to be hydrogen let's do that
for a couple of these other guys down
here so let's say we wanted to know how
much what is the mass of a molecule of
water fair enough enough water on the
planet you want to you want to know what
that is well we already know what the
the mass of a hydrogen is it's one right
hydrogen is one one atomic mass unit
oxygen is what oxygen is 16 so notice
it's exactly 16 so most of the planet
you pretty much you have
in an oxygen atom you have a tad you
have eight protons and exactly eight
neutrons so you get atomic mass of 16 so
oxygen has an atomic mass of 16 atomic
mass units so the atomic mass of the
entire molecule you have two hydrogen's
so you have two times the mass of
hydrogen plus one oxygen plus 16 so it
equals 18 atomic mass units for water
and once again if you want to say what
percent by mass of water is oxygen
what's 16 out of the 18 right is oxygen
so if we get the calculator back you get
16 divided by 18 is water so it's 88
point let's say round at eighty eight
point nine percent water a sorry eighty
eight point nine percent oxygen so
eighty eight point nine percent oxygen
so most of water is oxygen even though
and this is interesting even though you
have two hydrogen's here and you only
have you only even though you have two
hydrogen's for every one oxygen oxygens
mass is so much larger it's 16 times
larger that most of water is is oxygen
and now in the next let me think well
I'm probably running out of time so the
next video I'm going to talk about how
do we go backwards if someone gives you
the composition how can you get the
empirical formula and actually on a side
note slightly unrelated to what I just
talked about I was doing some research
last night about just you know could
about about metals because they're
actually interesting about you know why
some metals conduct more and some
conduct less and some sites because when
I first talked talked about you know
these were obviously the transition
metals there's their backfilling their D
orbitals and you know I said hey you
know the periodic table that was I think
that was in I think I was looking at a I
think I was looking in a Princeton
Review book that described these as
metals and described these as transition
metals I was okay you know that's kind
of not fair because I consider iron and
copper and gold and silver to be as
metallic as anything why should these be
called you know transition metals and
these be just called regular metals and
it actually turns out that
a common name for these are poor metals
poorer metals because to a large degree
there's their softer they have lower
melting points so the intuition was
right to a large degree these are when
we think of metals these are very these
you know these are the matte metals I
think of and when we think of metallic
nature and a chemist and a chemistry
sense we talked a lot about that who
wants to donate their electrons the most
that's metallic nature they're the guys
down here and then as you go to the top
right these want to donate their
electrons the least these are the most
electronegative they like electrons the
most so they actually have some of the
worst metallic nature so it actually
makes sense to call them poor metals
anyway I just wanted you and there's
some debate on whether these should even
be called poor metals it's kind of if
you look up a bunch of periodic table
some of will call these metals some will
call these poor metals but I just wanted
to throw that out there just so you're
exposed to it and so you know that for
me it is a little bit more intuitive to
call these poor metals because they have
less metallic nature than the stuff
especially down here the alkali and the
alkaline earth metals anyway see in the
next video